Europe is not built against
states or against nations which are not
a temporary invention of
history but which are established over
time we parliament and commission
we will act in the general interest and
I would like us to do so
together
the president of the commission is elected to
your assembly
that does not make him a recipient
of others I will not be the vale the
aide-de-camp of the european parliament
but do not doubt for a single second
my desire to put an end  to the function
of a commissioner in whom you would have to
gain your confidence nor my
desire to follow up, in principle, with
a legislative proposal
your interventions and your invitations
to this effect on Thursday to the government
to resist more often the 30th session of
criticism in  going home the
decisions you made together
in brussels don't say
if you have an eight in brussels don't say
no elsewhere never ever
say again after a
meeting of the european council and the
council that you have won a
victory and that the others  have lost in
europe we win together and it is
together that we lose
we must stop the ridicule of
having ourselves represented as one of the
strongest currencies of a
tartan ofppt of representatives who very often
contradict each other I would like  that the
economic and monetary union and that the euro
is represented not a single chair
by a single place by a single path
in the institutions of the dragon
the agreement will not be concluded at
any price we cannot abandon
our  health standards we
can't give up on our good man and
social we can't give up on
our data protection requirements
i wouldn't want
data protection to be part of
the negotiation with our american friends
i wish you  talk in more
detail about ukraine, whose people I would like
to greet today and tell them
that we are of the opinion that this people is
European and that it has its place in europe
I would have liked
I would have liked to express to you  in detail
why I consider it necessary that in
all the countries of the European Union we
put in place minimum social wages
and minimum income
for insertion or guaranteed minimum income
we will act in this direction be proud
to have put in place  the single currency
the single currency does not divide europe the
single currency protects europe
protects europe protects their
si during the events in ukraine
si during the economic and
financial crisis that hit us and
made us  europe is the epicenter of a
global battle we were still
in the european monetary system
europe today would be in
monetary war france against germany
germany against italy italy
against portugal and l  spain
all against all the euro its discipline
its ambitions ensure that we
have a monetary order that
protects us the euro protects europe
two singles
from Monday in the senate